tonight on the new reality an entire
city going under quarantine
it was scary to be honest with you i've
never seen
the city like that but one year later
wuhan is roaring back to life back to
school
and work everybody buys into the idea of
social distancing masking
and so they were able to eliminate the
virus
in a very short period of time i think
just the way they did it is pretty
amazing
how does a museum fulfill its mandate
with no visitors
our revenues are really based off of
people coming through these doors it was
just devastating
having gone through this experience it's
opened our minds to different methods of
telling a story
hello and welcome to the new reality i'm
donna friesen
a year ago the world was watching a
catastrophe unfold in wuhan china
infections and deaths from kovid19 were
soaring
millions of people were under strict
lockdown and cases were beginning to
appear in countries around the world
canada sent a plane to rescue canadians
who were stranded in the place where
this pandemic
started tonight jeff semple takes us
back to wuhan
to see how life has changed
lately bin john has been feeling
homesick
the married father of two grew up in
china and moved here to calgary when he
was 18.
he says people occasionally ask where
he's from but until last year
few had ever heard of his hometown of
wuhan
i certainly didn't want my hometown's
name to be well known in this way
in january 2020 jung planned to travel
to wuhan to visit his parents
his wife and children were already there
after arriving a few weeks earlier for
chinese new year
jung had heard reports of a strange new
virus but wasn't too concerned
until he was about to board his flight
to beijing and a headline
splashed across the screen
on this wednesday night an entire city
going under quarantine
it was such a surreal experience right
like nobody has
imagined things like this just the
thought of
me being separated from my family
from my kids was really scary right so
people are trying to get out of hu han
you're trying to get into wuhan
that's right how difficult was that so
once i landed in beijing i went
to the front desk and i said hey i have
a flight schedule to go into wuhan
and then they basically say what and i
said i'm flying to wuhan
and they said no you're not
so jung caught a flight to a city nearby
and drove the rest of the way
eventually reuniting with his family and
arriving to find his hometown
a ghost town it was scary to be honest
with you
i've never seen the city
like that the city of 11 million was
locked down cut off from the world for
76 days
some trapped inside witnessed terrifying
scenes
of panic and death
39 year old son died from kovid 19 after
she says he was forced to wait weeks to
receive
treatment with the hospitals overwhelmed
every day i suffer from imagining the
pain he went through she says
how he struggled and cried all alone
a couple of weeks into wuhan's lockdown
the canadian government sent a plane
to rescue its citizens and permanent
residents
including jung's family i was happier
than winning
a lottery we were you know just
completely relieved
that we're finally on home soil
but one year later that pandemic script
has flipped the first city in the world
to be devastated by the new coronavirus
now offers a glimpse into a
post-pandemic
future wuhan is roaring back to life
back to school and work
its residents can breathe easy knowing
there hasn't been a confirmed case of
covet 19 in this city
since last spring my mom is going out
playing mahjong with her friends
my dad is doing business as usual so
it's kind of i'm kind of jealous of what
they're doing
back there with alberta's covet 19
caseload climbing to record highs
zhang even considered taking his family
back to wuhan we did contemplate on
you know maybe flying back that way
because you know be safer for our kids
safer for us
but on the other hand you know calgary
is where
our home is the chinese communist party
meanwhile is declaring victory unveiling
a new
sprawling exhibition in wuhan hastily
built on the site of a former field
hospital it recounts and celebrates the
government's purported triumph over the
virus
featuring photos of chinese president xi
jinping
alongside medical workers even a
hospital
hologram i live
five hours away on a train but i came
especially for this exhibition she told
global news
i'm really touched i feel that our
country is really awesome
but this impressive display is also
remarkable
for what's missing no mention of the
whistleblowers
of how doctors like liwen liang who died
of kovid 19
first sounded the alarm against official
orders
warning the virus was spreading between
people
or the citizen journalists like zhang
jian sentenced to four years in prison
for challenging the government's version
of events
by posting videos like this one taken
inside a hospital
chinese state media is also promoting a
different kovid 19
origin story claiming the virus actually
originated in europe
and arrived in wuhan on a shipment of
frozen seafood
the seafood hypothesis does not make
sense to me and i suspect
that's probably more politically
motivated virologist angela rasmussen
says the closest relatives to covid19
are found in bats in china and there
have been no related viruses found in
any
european seafood it can take
multiple decades sometimes to identify
the zoonotic origin of any emerging
virus
a team of investigators with the world
health organization has just been
granted access to china
visiting the infamous wuhan market
linked to the first known outbreak
but residents here are less concerned
with where the virus started
and more about who's spreading it now
the covid cases are mainly from imported
food and people who come from abroad
this beijing resident says
parroting the communist party line
our government does a good job this
woman says but in the west
people prioritize their own opinions
ahead of the collective good
i think that's why it's out of control
in the west
indeed china's economic recovery stands
in sharp contrast to the kovid chaos
elsewhere in the world
while canada and others struggle china
was the only major economy that actually
grew last year
the country where the pandemic appears
to have started is now profiting
from it thanks in part to the sudden
unprecedented demand
for ppe even before the pandemic
china supplied most of the world's
personal protective equipment
but last year those exports skyrocketed
around 95 of canada's imported face
masks
came from china costing around one and a
half billion dollars
even while some canadian manufacturers
sat
on the sidelines when the pandemic's
first wave
crashed into canada back in the spring
this bc based manufacturer
pivoted to produce mass quantities of
ppe
the government was reaching out to
companies like ours we were getting
contacts from all sorts of different
people requesting different having
different types of ppe requests but the
president of layfield group mark rose
says after six months their masks remain
in the warehouse
caught in red tape the u.s
government agency that certifies medical
grade n95 masks
is dealing with a backlog and without
that certification
rose says they've struggled to sell to
local health authorities
our products are collecting dust on the
shelves we just can't get these to
market
and and the government seems to be
buying materials from
other markets other markets like china
but those pandemic purchases have
resulted in a laundry list of recalls
involving millions of chinese-made masks
including some that health canada
inspectors
found posed a health and safety risk to
their users
there are all kinds of quality problems
with those products
gordon zhang is the head of maple leaf
laboratories in bc
partnering with layfield group to
produce ppe
we cannot compete with overseas cheap
laborers
the government needs to support domestic
manufacturers
we've learned that we need to be much
more careful
in our collaborations with china those
words are especially cutting coming from
margaret mcquaid johnston
for more than 40 years holding senior
posts with the ontario and federal
governments
she was a champion of china and helped
to lay the groundwork for canada's
covid19 vaccine collaboration
that ended with the chinese suddenly
abandoning the clinical trials and
partnership last year
and withholding the vaccines it's really
been
tragic personally to see
how china has changed under xi jinping
china is no longer the country that we
once fell in love with but china's
success
is difficult to deny
china reported just 2 000 domestic cases
of kovid 19
in january that's fewer new infections
in a month than ontario saw in an
average day
experts note its residents were already
used to wearing masks after the sars
epidemic
and the elderly here tend to live with
their families not in care homes
but above all chong believes that
wuhan's lockdown
worked residents had to follow its
orders of course
but zhang says they also wanted to
they never had any anti-mass protests
everybody buys into the idea of social
distancing masking
and so they were able to eliminate the
virus
in a very short period of time but
here i'm just not too sure
that we can get to that level of
engagement
although we should and we should
definitely try
i think just the way they did it is
pretty pretty amazing
coming up on the new reality this
exhibition is called pandemic pastimes
early on in the pandemic the federal
government recognized the value of the
country's small museums and
put together an emergency support fund
it could have been a time to kind of
sulk
and cry and whine but it turned into
let's empower
our museum and then in turn empower our
community
if we're not connected to our past there
is a danger we'll forget it
and across this country the places that
collect historical and cultural
artifacts
are suffering hundreds of small museums
are struggling financially because of
the pandemic
and have closed the challenge they face
is not just trying to connect with the
community
but to record and preserve what will go
down in history
as one of the most significant moments
in a generation
tonight david aiken takes us inside some
of these cultural
touch points
africville a village on the south shore
of the bedford basin in halifax
first settled in the early 1800s
residents in this close-knit community
faced racism neglect and were denied
basic municipal services
by the late 1960s its 400 residents
black nova scotians were forcibly
removed
their homes were raised their 150 year
old church
destroyed in the middle of the night the
city council of the day called it
urban renewal and wanted africville's
land for commercial development
room enough to build the bridge it would
take
40 years until 2010 when the city
formally
apologized and provided some of the
funding to build the africville museum
created as a replica of the seaview
united baptist church
that had been destroyed decades earlier
juanita peters
is the museum's executive director it
was a cultural hub for the african nova
scotian community especially people of
africville
but today as a museum it's it serves to
welcome people into this space and and
see why this space was so important to
people of africville but this museum
like so many others across the country
has not been able to welcome anyone into
this space
since the pandemic forced museums to
close their doors to visitors
last march when the pandemic hit
you know our revenues are really based
off of people coming through these doors
and buying product at the door having
conversations
you know it was it was just devastating
possibly worse
how does a museum fulfill its mandate
with no visitors
the answer in africville a cookbook what
is the thing that often brings us
together food it was such a great
challenge
an africville cookbook would step in as
the replacement for the popular annual
africville reunion normally held every
july in the park
next to the museum they're on the land
they're together they're sharing stories
they're cooking they're eating
and of course because of the pandemic
they could not come this year
the museum tracked down former
africville residents mostly women
many who had never written down any of
their recipes and compiled a history of
the breakfast that fueled the day's
labor lunches on the fly and
dinners that workers would come home to
at night you know these fish cakes are
good for
breakfast lunch or suppers and it turns
out
the cookbook reached beyond the museum's
walls
to be a tangible way to connect the
community that the institution
serves food is a universal language so
it actually
ties people from all over the country
and beyond
early on in the pandemic the federal
government recognized the value of the
country's small museums and
put together an emergency support fund
more than
1200 institutions tapped into that fund
which dispersed more than 33 million
dollars
afrofield museum received about thirty
one thousand dollars
money that helped replace revenue from
lost ticket and
gift shop sales but it's not just money
that helps museums meet their mandate
it's also volunteers consider this the
last federal head count of who does the
work in museums or art galleries
found more than 7 300 full-time
employees
more than 11 000 part-timers and a
whopping
69 949 volunteers
who provided a combined 4.3 million
hours of free labor
to the country's museums helping hands
that all but disappeared with the
pandemic
and so in a museum like the one in swift
current saskatchewan
it was up to the paid staff just for
them to carry on
and carry on they did first order of
business
mask everyone up even the stuffed bison
that's been there since 1949.
a teenager named ranger and ranger
because of the pandemic is of course
wearing his mask
lloyd begley the curator at swift
currents museum even tried to get a mask
on the other
must-see exhibit in his collection a
37-foot moses sore
discovered in southwest saskatchewan in
1993.
i tried to use a pillowcase and it just
wouldn't fit his mouth was too big the
pandemic has made the museum a
relatively lonely place for
ranger and the dinosaur so now we have
to figure out ways to to get our message
out to the to the community
by doing programming solution
mountain exhibition with the public's
help to document how those in southwest
saskatchewan
lived through the first lockdown this
exhibition is called pandemic pastimes
photographs and stories about what life
was like
during the 2020 pandemic the closing of
the skate park
the closing of the playgrounds stephanie
caduck is the museum's
education and public programs
coordinator and she says
all these artifacts will be archived by
the museum
for future researchers so a hundred
years from now
people are going to be able to actually
do an exhibition
and have local information this was a
museum
having been given a lemon figured out
how to make lemonade
ottawa gave it about fifty six thousand
dollars to carry on
having gone through this experience it's
opened our minds to sort of different
methods of communication rather than
traditional interpretation of historical
method
or telling a story
in west kelowna after years of planning
the west bank first nation had just
relocated its museum to brand new digs
in this mall in february
and was preparing for a busy spring then
the pandemic hit
museum assistant coralie miller said the
news was tough to take
and when we had to cancel all of that it
was very disheartening but we knew that
we weren't going to be out of work
because there's always work that needs
to be done
within a museum jordan koble a counselor
for west bank first nation
has been one of the driving forces
behind the museum
it could have been a time to kind of
sulk and cry and whine but it turned
into
let's empower our museum let's empower
the staff and then in turn empower our
community to say we got this
the museum preserves and celebrates the
history and culture of the
west bank first nation and the silk or
okanagan peoples
so if visitors could not travel the
museum would
via video on the web okay let's go
it started off with just using a phone
um
and the the phone microphone so it was
wasn't the best quality in the beginning
but baby steps
again the fed stepped in with 28
thousand dollars in emergency funding
assistance
among other things the museum upgraded
their video equipment
now kate she will put the camera on a
tripod stick it on a rolly chair and
chase me around the museum so
it's like we're back in business baby
just digitally
corley's videos were the shiny light and
such a
dark period for our community for our
nation for the world
when the pandemic struck there was such
fear anxiety concern
there's too much doom and gloom on the
news already at least with this we can
get people to forget about their
problems at least
just for a little bit the videos are now
core
to the museum's mandate it's important
for our children to understand
who they are their family members their
relationships to the community their
relationships to the land that surrounds
us
but more importantly the
responsibilities and in that sense be it
west kelowna swift current halifax or
in many other places in the country
canada's museums and galleries despite
all the obstacles of a pandemic
are meeting the challenge of what will
surely be the most significant
historical event of their generation
it can get pretty lonesome and it can
feel a little debilitating
when um the work becomes feels like it's
three times harder to get the same
results but when you're doing it
with others who are either more
experienced
and it just it just makes the work that
much more fun
next week on the new reality there's not
enough governing bodies
infrastructures places to celebrate
black excellence
think about all we have lost
think about the stories that haven't
been told think about
the people with the talent that we
haven't seen why did you and your
brother feel the need to start
the black academy we didn't want to you
know continuously be lost in this
perpetual loop
of you know canada not recognizing and
supporting
you know their black talent that is the
new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen thanks for watching
you